hello people welcome to the Ruben report
I'm Dave ruin and I am incredibly
excited today because once in the
history of the Ruben report did we do a
show that never aired never made it all
the way to YouTube the guests on that
show were Gina grad and Ben moitz why
did that show not air was it something
so controversial it was too hot it was
incredibly hot we were sweating our
balls off no we didn't record it it just
didn't get recorded So I said to them
please come back and 6 months later with
their busy schedules they're here
welcome to the show guys thank busy
schedules I'm like here every day yeah
and I hardly were but you're you're in
the kitchen a lot you're doing a lot of
things and you know you're you're around
the pots and pans I chill I play with
the dog outside yeah yeah anyway I
believe we are recording Today's Show I
feel confident about that so let's get
to it uh you guys may have heard about
this big Comcast Time Warner merger they
have joined evil forces uh it's a
basically comp bought time water for $45
billion that's billion with a b and uh
Comcast is known as one of the biggest
Spenders in all politics they have over
a hundred lobbyists in uh in DC uh and I
love this so there was a big
Congressional uh committee on the merger
and uh you're not going to believe this
but uh Comcast has donated money to all
18 members of that said committee uh
let's look at some of the donations uh
Senator Durban from m 54,000 from
Comcast which is the most of any Senator
on the committee uh Orin hatch got
45,000 uh Ley up in Vermont 52 uh Mike
Lee 17 uh Al Franken
5,000 uh Al Franken also is the only one
to oppose the merger uh and
interestingly he got the least amount of
money can you believe that I find that
hard to believe uh we've got video Al
Franken talking about the merger let's
go to that I think Comcast uh does give
give money to people who support them NE
not necessarily to buy their support but
uh I yeah I I really don't like the role
of money in politics and I think it's
just gotten worse and worse and worse I
think citizens united was a very
disturbing uh pernicious ruling I think
this slatest McCutchen rule ruling was
was awful I you know it's just giving
more power to those who have have
money you like that so funny you like
that
pricious it's a funny word it's a funny
word so uh just to clarify in case you
weren't listening to Mr Franken the guy
who's getting the least amount of money
is the only one fighting it but he does
want you to know uh that it's not about
the money um is that really just is that
the sad part here before we get to the
merger that the one guy who's fighting
it is getting the least but yet even he
he even goes on television to say it's
not that they've been bought off even
though we know that they I I I I don't I
I think he's right and I think we look
at it to he his point is bigger the
money in politics is the problem there
are going to be people who oppose this
merger at like I'm going to make stuff
up here Viacom say and they give a ton
of money too right so at some point on
issues like this you're getting money
from both sides so you're you're
probably free to vote your conscience
the problem is that whether Viacom
opposes it or or comcast fights for it
nobody in there is fighting for
consumers so whether this merger happens
or not it's not like if this merger is
denied it's not a great victory for the
American Consumer like we're sort of
screwed either way but it's a little
Victory right because then hopefully
there's some more competition and prices
but I mean we've lost there was so there
is basically so our big debate is
whether there are four giant multimedia
companies running everything or five or
three like it's a problem either way and
let's be honest unless you're me $5,000
is not a lot money so that I don't I
think that that should just be taken off
the table to begin with who gives a
$5,000 so we should give Al Franken
extra credit then because 5,000 is
nothing anyway anything to do with it I
I mean why would it it's $5,000 is the
50,000 a lot because so dick Durban who
got the most 50,000 in the course of a
campaign and all that is actually
nothing too so is that enough to buy a
guy or I guess that go I mean I presume
like I don't know who else is fighting
this but I guess the way that some
Airlines fight mergers of other airlines
because it'll be create too much
competition for them I was probably
right that if if IC come even a is that
a thing is that a thing but I imagine
like they own CBS so so I imagine that
they don't that they don't want this and
I imagine that that the other that you
know AT&T Erse or Verizon FiOS they
don't they might not want this but
everyone's too afraid to say anything
like all of these huge companies that
are gigantic corporations are are
totally unwilling to fight this right so
why is that they're huge companies too
yeah I read that I'm curious whether the
big companies are unwilling to fight it
or certainly the the the mom and pop
right the mom the mom and pop million
dollar companies but right I mean
because this is a a marriage of what the
one and two biggest cable providers and
the one and three biggest Broadband
providers but you know then the the the
content providers are the people who are
could also be screwed by this as they
could price fix yeah for how much they
pay for each networks programs but they
don't want to fight it because they
don't want to be in a disadvantageous
position I suspect that in some sense
the only people capable of fighting this
are other media giants like I mean the
great like where's Fox when you need
them to step in and fight this like I
can't believe I'm like I wish rert
Murdoch would jump in and fight for me
like always right or yeah or maybe
Google could do something about this
Google Fiber is coming Amazon somebody
it's it matters these but but it sounds
like when Al Franken is the lone voice
it sounds like you know when you you
have support from Orin hatch and Dick
Durban it's a reminder that sometimes on
big issues like this the parties don't
matter yeah what what's going on in
Minnesota you know Minnesota gave us the
one independent Governor we've had Jesse
Ventura and they've given us Al Franken
who's basically an independent for all
intensive purposes what's going on up
there that you can get a place that
gives us Michelle Bachman also gives us
these independent two words cheese curds
they do they I'm telling you they make
people act in ridiculous ways I thought
you I thought you were going to go with
ice fishing m
M you're watching Fargo what the hell's
going on I saw Fargo last night it was
very good a lot of fun really well done
I mean well you know Michelle Bachman in
a very specific District Franken by the
way I mean he shows some Independence
but he's a Democrat I mean you know he's
a and Jessie Ventura remember had some
interesting fun things but uh he lives
in Mexico Off the Grid he's off the grid
he even has a new show I'm doing it next
week it's called off the grid but and
what about the anti are we just done
with the antitrust situation do we does
that just not that's not a thing anymore
nobody cares well it reminds me of money
in politics we used to we talk about it
here all the time but politicians used
to talk about money and politics there
was something called the McCain fine
gold Bill gone you know like nobody
talks about it so I think it's much we
don't care anymore that's over William
Howard ta is attempting to roll over in
great but he can't yeah because there's
so many time water cables like going
through J that was was a was a dead fat
joke fat I took a sound fat joke and I
turned it into cable J that's pathetic
well Ben it might have something to do
with a former FCC chairman who is now
Comcast senior vice president maybe that
has something to do with why things
can't happen maybe it's because uh
Comcast CEO Brian Roberts played golf
with Obama I don't know if any of these
things are connected um so final thought
on this uh is this just going to uh make
it so that we're just going to
consistently see worse and worse service
I mean that's ultimately what the
concern is that our Internet is just
going to keep getting slower or it's
going to be throttled so that they'll
throttle Netflix if they're not in
partnership with Netflix as you were
saying well yeah yeah I mean everybody
wants the same thing everybody wants the
most they can get for the little the
littlest they have to put into it and
that's what the the cable companies want
they want to get the most from us by
having to do the least so and they have
way more money and power and stuff than
we have so yeah of course I already see
it I'm a Verizon VES customer and for
some time with fos and with one other
Netflix was slowed down it was so I mean
I watched House of card season 2 and I
watched you know I mean the things you
have to put up with in this country it
took you 49 minutes instead of 46 oh no
it took me 46 minutes but it wasn't a
perfect HD quality picture you weren't
getting 10 yeah right you were on 720 no
I yeah I was at 720 at most and
sometimes it would be like a little
blurry wow yeah I mean Jesus it's like
sorry for your loss yeah I mean this is
uh yeah I mean granted like my
daughter's not hungry right but it's
like the same thing she have a 10
fingers 10 toes she has 10 fingers 10
little fingers and 10 little toes she
does yeah yeah good please send all your
condolences to Ben M77 on the Twitter
but that's a big deal real quick I know
we got to go but that's a big deal not
my Netflix problem but as you mentioned
when when they're just going to start
there's going to be most favored nation
status and and I just don't see any way
that anyone standing up to make that
stop except for people like Elizabeth
Warren right so by the way if you're
just if you're a young Turks fan in
general we are on YouTube here so we are
the type of company that could be
affected by this because the big boys
could get in bed with other online media
things and be like Oh The Young Turks
they're actually telling the truth we're
going to slow down their videos so
that's why this stuff is all important
so uh we'll put a link to an article uh
in the description and you can find out
more but let's move on and talk about
other giant corporations doing crazy
things uh Google you know we've talked a
lot about Google Glass but even before
most people are on the Google Glass
Google contact lenses are on the way uh
we've got an image how it works uh the
Google contact lens contains a control
circuit and an image capture camera
component and an image sensor it can be
wirelessly linked to a mobile phone for
data access and to issue commands via
audio the system will be able to detect
faces potentially allowing the blind to
recognize people okay so there's a lot
of good stuff the medical stuff helping
the blind obviously great um so we've
talked a lot about Google Glass here and
I firm believer it's going to completely
change how we all act if your glasses
right now because they already have that
it's going to be able to be put in
designer glasses you're going to be able
to be recording us imagine if like
you're still going to have to have
something yeah I know very upsetting
that would be terrible but it seems like
we're already skipping ahead like we're
going to have Google Glass for like a
couple months and you know some people
have it already but we're going to have
it for a couple months and then bang
it's going to be in contact lenses is
this scary people say always say well
Dave you're against science when I when
I do this you're against technology
because I don't want to be recorded at
every second what do you think I'm I'm
split on this because at first I'm like
oh this is super like Logan's Run and
then they're going to like pop my
eyeball out when I get to a certain age
it's going to be horrible but then it's
like you know you're already at that age
it's too late seriously go yourself
um but then it's like you think about
like clear implants and all this stuff
that makes deaf people be able to hear
and if this is that if this if this can
be that for blind people that are
talking about I don't know I didn't
realize so many people are having
diabetes problems with diabetes but they
said that that to regulate their glucose
this is going to be really helpful
that's cool but is that what this is
really about I doubt it right somehow
this will really be about porn right
isn't that how it all goes that porn
leads the way with technology I I don't
I'm not sold on Google Glass I've been
wrong on a lot of stuff I think it until
I see something that indicate people
want to distort their faces and right
now it's a facial Distortion do you
think it'll go the way of the laser disc
it might I mean some it's not like we've
had like it'll work and some but walking
around having to touch your glasses like
there's going to come a point where
where it's too it's too upsetting into
our Reg lives and right now Google Glass
looks like it I get it there's going to
be some cool component there might be
some time that you want to do it yeah
well I wasn't kidding I mean they're
going to they're already making designer
glasses with so it's not as obtrusive as
no but it's still you still it still has
to have the camera right but the people
who are wearing Google Glasses want you
to know they wearing Google Glasses
right so we're reading the story on it
and like in paragraph nine what it was
included in your list there Dave is like
and it might might also help the contact
lenses might also help the blind see and
I'm like they really buried that lead I
would have led with that I I would have
opened with we can cure blindness yeah
yeah you think that's more important
yeah maybe wow no sh that's a big deal
that's a thing yeah that actually was
second to glucose checking your glucose
yeah yeah cuz that's what that's what
they were invented for to read the
glucose for diabetics so they can
constantly monitor the levels which you
mentioned because it can be read in the
uh tears your tears that's fascinating
all right so I think what you're both
saying is I should stop being so fearful
of where this All Leads or I've just
watched so many science fiction movies
and smoke so much pot at the same time
that I always see everything where the
robots come get us I don't doubt that at
all that you've done that but here's the
thing if I'm holding my phone yeah I'm
probably recording you so it's like what
just as a public service to you but
that's the thing it's like you say I
don't want to be recorded I don't want
to you know it's making you paranoid but
we're all already being recorded all the
time whether you like it or not whether
you know it or not so how is the glass
how are the glasses any different yeah
do you think uh we're going to have
places ultimately I think they they've
been popping up already I think there's
a bar in Portland where people are
they're banning Google Glass but do you
think we're going to have like
technology free zones like where you're
going to go to dinner and they're not
they're going to literally take your
phone and that yeah yeah there already
are some there's places I I went to to
work a little office place I mean it's
not technology free because everybody
there is working on their screenplay on
their computers but I mean you can't
talk on the phone you can't there can't
be any noise and I think there'll be
more of that I I I just like 3D glasses
like 3D TVs and maybe that will take
over but and the moment that you make
people watch television or watch a movie
and force them to put heavy glasses on
first them to put something on their
face I just think it's different I'm not
I I I'm prepared to be wrong but my
hunch is that something will get in the
way yeah well that's just the small step
before the the contact lenses and then
that may that may be the proof that but
also who can touch their eye I mean I
know there's a lot of contact lens wears
but Jesus how do you people do that I've
never have you ever worn contact oh yeah
I worn them for years I still wear them
to play uh you know when I decided to be
an
athlete played softball last night
D-League Santa Monica okay let's move on
uh let's talk about the year 2060 I I
thought this story was really
interesting uh Pew research uh has done
a little study they're calling the next
America basically what America's
demographics are going to look like in
the year 2060 now I read a book recently
uh 2030 by Albert Brooks and basically
it's everything that he predicted but
they're saying it's going to take an
extra 30 years uh so let's let's look at
some stuff
here okay so this is the the racial
breakdown and how it's going to change
massively and if you're one of these
white people that want to only be around
white people you're not going to be
happy in 2060 uh so by 2060 nonwhites
will make up 57% of the population uh
mainly because of immigration shifts but
also because of birth rates and things
of that nature uh and then what I think
is even more fascinating is this next
piece we're going to show you and I
believe it's
animated okay so in most societies if
you were to look at uh pyram you have
all the young people on the bottom and
then because people age and die it's a
it's a pyramid so it gets narrower at
the top what's happening and what's
going to continue to happen in America
because of Science and because of our
shifting demographics uh is that we're
starting to get a square so we're going
to have as many old people as we do
young people which is going to affect
the economy and is going to affect
health and all kinds of things Ben well
earlier in a previous segment on the
show we were talking about the benefits
of Logan's Run when people reached a
certain age and were taken to Sanctuary
right and I this chart proves the value
the societal value of Logan's Run with
Michael York well y Michael York that's
right so Logan's Run and 2030 by Albert
Brooks which I hope they make into a
movie have sort of predicted this
because what he was predicting is that
the next sort of Civil War we're going
to have is going to be an age War
because young people are going to be
sick of putting all their money to
sustain old people who keep living
longer and longer and there's going to
be less young people and more old people
should we talk about the young old first
or the race what are you feeling first
well can we first very Qui can we go
back to the first chart let's go back to
the first chart I kind of I kind of
glossed over that I just I just and I
was born in 1967 but look back at 1960 I
mean we were
winning look at that white power
85 that is some real supremacist and the
Asians like who gives a they're
barely even on there that was great
those were good guys yeah they barely
charted what did Jewish guys do in 1960
exactly yeah well and and I don't I
don't know personally if it's you did
really good um I don't even know is it
about race or is it about religion
because you know the more you talk about
this and you think whatever I don't know
if this is politically insensitive I I
don't know I'm justy I'm brainstorming
fall in here but you know they they said
the Hispanic population has increased so
much and will keep increasing is that
because of uh Catholicism is that a lack
of birth control because of religious
belief I think it's all of those things
yeah I it just seems like it's more it's
possible that it's more about that than
about actual race yeah I don't know but
that's just my thinking what do you make
of the uh you know Bill O'Reilly always
talks about like the the old America of
the 50s as it was so great and we've
lost our way since then but what he's
really talking about is the 85% white I
think that's what he's really hearkening
back to without saying it um do you
think white people are going to be okay
in 2060 part of this is that a
realization by white people that that
they can don't have to only other
white
people that's a big it's a big part of
this right that's a good point everyone
in that chart can anyone in that
chart that's and that would be great to
mix this whole thing everybody has to do
their part create future people yeah
that I enjoy very very much yeah um okay
so white white people are going to be
okay but what is it that you think that
they're always what do they fear like
Fox News people what do they really Fe
they Fe change they fear and I and well
and I mean really mean they fear change
in the sense that they fear a loss of
what they had and you know it's human
instinct to when something was good and
you feel it slipping away you want to
grab on to it and they're trying to grab
on to that way of life they feel oddly
threatened every time that you know a
you know a black guy raises his fist in
the air or a a Mexican or a Salvadoran
fights for immigration rights or an
Asian goes to Berkeley you know and and
the funny thing about that is these
people who are trying to better their
lives better their circumstances it
seems that these particular people these
particular white people are taking that
super personally so it's not about them
as if it's coming from them exactly
right well but it is they're not they're
not totally wrong some of it is coming
from them and that's you know look
that's okay it always came from somebody
it just went to a different white person
but the whole every Republican lately
and has run for president on that theory
of fear and that Fe is that things are
changing and the things you loved and
the things you knew and the things
mostly that you could count on in the
future are being taken from you by the
others and you know when the others were
at 14% it wasn't that bad when the
others were 24% they started to get a
little uncomfortable and now when the
others are 57% yeah like there's nothing
we can do to stop this so shouldn't
everyone be embracing it more that our
society is going to change we had a
different ethnic makeup in the 1950s and
it's going to change and be okay people
don't think that it's going to be the
same that's what you were saying people
don't think it's well it's going to be
more Asian it's going to be more
Hispanic it's going to be more black but
other than that it's totally the same
people are are filling in the blanks
like racist Mad Lib style about what
goes along with that change and that's
what they're terrified of didn't we
didn't we have a Melting Pot wasn't
there something about a Melting Pot in
America tired what about that Melting
Pot what happened that thing I mean the
melting it was a great a great
concept until Bill O'Reilly looked in
the pot you know and he was like holy
pot is Brown
yeah this is gumbo but and for
Republicans it's going to be they're
doomed see like you know what I'm fine
with this Melting Pot as long as it's a
broth right totally that's right as long
it's a very clear broth yeah but they're
doomed unless they I mean it really
calls for a policy change because and
significant policy changes because
there's nothing as long as they're seen
as hostile to Latinos they're Doom they
have to get a significant portion of
that and the only way they're going to
do it is by having some policy
recognitions and I think that's going to
I I think they'll do it because I think
the need to survive ultimately will win
out but there's no possible way to hang
on to electoral majorities without
cultivating some minority vote and as
Gina said there's you know the lack of
birth control strong families deeply
religious values there's a lot of
reasons to think that Republicans could
latch on sure to plenty of Latinos Ben
are you implying that that might be why
Jeb Bush said that immigration is an act
of love do you think it was a calculated
political move well I think yeah I mean
I think it was a calculated political
move he might also believe it but either
way he's right you know uh all right so
final thought on this the age thing
which I actually think is the most
interesting part of this because we talk
about race all the time uh are we going
to have a major problem dealing with old
people because they're for reason I mean
believe me I I love The Golden Girls
more than anyone but am I going to start
hating old people because they're going
to be mooching off the system we're
going to have young less young people
putting money into the system and these
people because of science are going to
keep living longer and longer and longer
well and it also creates this sort of
vicious cycle because you know people
aren't going to want to start you know
having families and supporting you know
little teeny tiny tots if they're
already putting so much money into
supporting their parents their
grandparents other people's grandparents
right so which we already see now
Millennials are having kids way less
even Gen X are having kids way later
than
idiocracy a great movie y um Ben bring
us home on idiocracy you must have seen
it Mr movie I have I didn't like it
uh I can't remember it's a cautionary T
it is it's a great movie no we but the
the one Obamacare is a is critical for
this because you get the young people
forced to pay and forced to buy which
will help pay for it right I mean it's
incredible there was significant
foresight in that plus it has the death
panels to take out some of
those problem solved you see it's all
going to work itself out okay let's talk
about cloning uh the first ever dog has
been cloned in England and we've got a
picture of the Clone Doxon mini winnie
no a there's Minnie Winnie that is the
first clone dog out of Britain very
exciting how did they do it let's find
out the soam biotech firm took a tissue
sample of Winnie and stored it in a
liquid nitrogen as it was transported to
South Korea upon arrival cells from the
tissue sample were put into eggs from a
donor of the dog from the same breed
creating a cloned embryo the embryo is
then implanted into a surrogate dog and
mini was born later by c section all
right there there's a little a little
science for you um clone dogs we knew
this we knew this was coming clone dogs
100,000 bucks by the way yeah does that
seem how does the price tag seem steep
that seems a lot for the Clone dog I
mean you could go to a rescue and grab
one for 10 bucks with vaccinations yeah
you grab 10 exactly they'll give you
gladly you're big dog guy 100,000 bucks
for a clone dog too much no I mean a
dollar for a clone dog is too much
because you're such a rescue guy and but
you you have had dogs that you love and
their family I've had dogs that I love
in their family but you have the other
kind of animal inexplicably that you oh
are you a Catwoman look oh then this I
have to change my notes here cuz I was
going to r r on some cats cat please
bring it they're they're lovely
creatures uh if they hate you there's
probably a good reason but you were
saying the uh look there are it's not a
little thing there's where the shelters
are overrun they're killing dogs across
the country on a regular basis like if
you love dogs like this woman does and
she loves Winnie and that's great and
Winnie's 12 and Winnie's going to die
get another dog you owe it to Winnie to
to get as many dogs as you can
comfortably take care of if you're a dog
person like I I got a dog three weeks
after the greatest dog in the world
rookie died or four weeks after he died
and and I got it because I you know I
one I was lonely but two I like felt
like I'm supposed to haveg dogs I'm
supposed to take care of a dog yeah and
I thought you know whatever in my lame
way rookie would want that mostly rookie
would wanted wouldn't give a right
to be honest but um but allg I just
thought that was important and and so
don't clone a freaking dog for $100,000
they're these great dogs go get them go
take care of them right so we've already
got the Breeders doing this and they're
as you said they're putting down
literally thousands of dogs every day
well and they're also saying there is
there is absolutely no not even close to
a guarantee that this dog is going to be
anything like the dog you remember
nothing I mean it's it's it's tissue but
the way you treat it the way it's
brought up the it it has it will have
different brain chemistries right so
this it's like they didn't even see
multiplicity the first one was kind of
like Michael gon but then it gets disapp
that eighth one yeah yeah ah God the
worst uh but yes that is a good point
because all of us if you were to think
if you were going to clone a human then
wouldn't its experiences and its life
experiences
a resue from New Orleans krina think she
Liv that now made as and great as she is
if I was to clone her I have no reason
to believe she would be anything the
closest by did you just as a side note
did you have like a $20 bet with
somebody that you could work Michael
Keon into Today's Show yeah with Michael
Keaton I was just wondering yeah right
Michael Keaton and Michael York but and
that's the thing I mean that that's I
think it's the logical next question
when you talk about doing this with
animals if you God forbid lost a child
at a young age and someone said hey we
could give you another shot at this kid
yeah what do you do well is there ethic
difference an ethical difference between
doing this with uh animals and doing it
with humans because obviously the next
step in this and we're going to it's
going to happen in our lifetime will be
humans yeah there's of course there's a
difference I mean I love dogs but
they're dogs they don't have souls Ben
is that what you're telling me dogs
don't have souls uh they have their
souls are different they're doggy Souls
they're a little doggy Souls they're fur
furry Souls anyway I love Bob Bob's a
good girl but uh but didn't Bob kill a
cat no no pety killed a cat he didn't
kill cat he just ate tore the toes off
he just oh my God that's so much worse
he just jumped through a car window and
bit the toes off it's not a big deal
yeah are you serious yeah oh Ben yeah it
was it was pre Ben it was before I had
control of him well you say right here
and now that you will not clone that dog
you can't clone that
dog like a geyser yeah like you're not
going to CL that dog cat doesn't mean he
what you're not going to clone that dog
I'm not going to clone I'm not I'm not
going to clone that dog not going to
clone py all right I don't know that we
fully got everything we needed to get
out of that segment but you got the idea
they're cloning dogs it's wrong it's
wrong it's it's wrong it's wrong now the
anti-science people there we go all
right let's talk about
progress it's true all right let's talk
about porn uh we always find these
fascinating studies about porn habits in
the United State what state is watching
what a lot of weird stuff in the South
usually uh but we found one based on
political partisanship the Democrats
versus Republicans what porn they're
watching and this was uh a study done by
BuzzFeed they teamed up with the fine
folks over at
pornhub.com and uh let's see what they
found out so Democrats are watching more
porn than Republicans I was surprised we
think that Republicans are hiding in
their room watching uh the weird porn
and they are just a teeny bit less just
it's it's not a huge so this is Page
views per capita uh over 12 months study
there's a 13% difference so Democrats
are watching 133% uh more porn uh let's
look at the top red States this is Page
views per capita we have someone from
Kansas how does that make you feel proud
very very proud yeah so feel good about
this let let it fly man what do you
think's going on in Kansas that they're
watching uh so much point I don't know I
was actually shocked by this because I
love the good people of the great state
of Kansas the Bread Basket the Great
Plains if you will um it is where I hail
from geographic center of the United
States of America is that what they say
literally the heart land um and I I know
many canons that uh pretty uh pretty
pretty boring so this actually sh almost
like they don't get out a lot because
they're they're too busy jerking it to
porn inside like but I was actually
really surprised by this I don't I don't
think there's really anything wrong with
you know people watching porn so if they
my people want to do that I say God
bless I also don't think there's
anything wrong with watching por let's
look at the top blue states of course
blue means democratic if you're new to
this
game Nevada it's from being around Harry
Reid he's so boring that these people
feel like they need boring or super
hot synonymous yeah uh Illinois Colorado
Massachusetts etc etc I'm surprised to
Colorado because Colorado which
inexplicably borders Kansas which just
doesn't doesn't make an ounce of sense
right Colorado it's the part of Kansas
that nobody really inhabits yeah and
then the part of Colorado that nobody
thinks is Colorado connection you got to
go like 300 miles in Colorado before you
see a freaking mountain right and uh but
uh but I figure in Kansas it's first of
all it's very cold and it's it's it's
flat and there's nothing to stop the
wind and the cold and so people stay in
to watch porn and then when it's not
cold when it's nice out you go outside
and you're like oh there's still
nothing to do and then they just go go
back inside right yeah but Colorado
surprises me because it's uh you know
it's outdoors and vigorous and exciting
in the American West are you guys
surprised that Democrats watch more porn
even though it's only 133% there's only
so much you can glean out of studies
like this but isn't it surprising like
does it seem like the first study where
you think that it's going to turn out
the conservatives watch more it didn't
turn out that way I'm a little surprised
because it turns out the people who you
think would watch more porn because
they're more sort of sexually
Progressive and open are the people who
watch more porn right right but we
always think it's the worst it's the
other way well yeah you're right we
thought I think we all thought this was
going to come out of like repress and
like
aha but like it turns out you know
there's probably some truths if you're a
little more liberal you're probably a
little more liberal with your uh
joystick and you know you know a lot of
us believe and say on Young Turk shows
all the time that that you know like the
the most anti-gay congressman and the
most stridently anti-gay people are
probably secretly gay I really don't I I
seldom buy that I don't think I just
think they're they're unse secretly
hateful yeah and I don't and so I don't
think there's some like I don't think
they home you have led your ambition I
do I just think they're bad people I
don't think they're trying to I don't
think they're hiding something I just
think this is n this is who they are and
they blow that can we at least pretend
that the majority of the canons uh
staying home and yanking it to porn are
all in the Westboro Baptist Church
compound oh that would be nice to know
for the purposes of this segment we sure
can we can yeah uh we'd have I'd be
remiss if we didn't talk about
independence in a porn study about this
what do you think The Independents are
they watching a lot of porn they're
clearly masturbating alone
they got to be they got to be right in
the middle yeah they're right in the
middle so they're just they're right
there not as much as the Democrats not
as little as the Republicans yeah
they're probably you know what I bet
they're as much as the Democrats because
there's some degree of repression
happening with Republicans that just
won't let them do it even in the privacy
of that but they're independent they
don't care what you think they'll do
whatever they want they'll sit there all
day and independents are basically
gutless and unwilling to make an
important decision in their lives all
right speaking of important decisions in
Germany they are going to have public
nudist spaces in the city not just at
beaches that's right they're going to
have six Urban naked zones around the
city where people will be freed to
sunbathed naked we don't have any images
for this sorry but as we just said in
the previous segment there's plenty of
porn online hey guys just ask
nicely this is where everyone comments
on Gina's boobs thank you Urban naked
zone right here at the Young jks yes so
there uh this started because uh there
was an expiration of legis a for new
sunbathing in Bavaria uh of which Munich
is the capital and city leaders had to
to decide can people strip in public now
or what so they're just going to have
these little naked zones and this is
literally going to be like there's going
to be people working in offices and then
just you know a few feet away some naked
zones uh we could never do this in
America could we no and they shouldn't
do it in Germany because uh German
Germany's up and it's always been
up and this is just another
up thing like this leads to a
weird political party doesn't it no it
does lead to a weird political party
that's a great point but you know we
were just talking about the porn story
and like when you watch porn and then
you stumble on German porn you realize
oh dear God yeah Jesus I hope she's okay
you know okay wait yeah can you explain
German porn a little more because I
honestly I'm not really sure what German
porn is but every time we've done a a
thing on porn in this someone says that
about German porn and then people start
going what's the deal with German porn
super aggressive very super aggressive
there's a lot of choking and a lot of
regurgitating yeah it's not uh it's not
I mean I've only watched like 15 20
hours of it and it's
aert it will turn no it's a you know one
of the first of Jen tells a great story
one of the First videos when he was
given a you know a VHS porn was German
porn yeah and one of the lines first of
all everything said even even like you
know oh baby it feels so good I just
want to be inside you and make you feel
wonderful even that sounds hideous in
German um but there's a line in there
that was I'm going to get it slightly
wrong but it's essentially SLO and d
vitamine right which just again sounds
like you papers right um oh my God and I
was only following orders right I was
only following ORD it mean it means um
drink it up it's good for
you yeah if I might butt in thanks cuz I
love where this is going but I think
that that's I think that that's a a
major uh comment on on our society and
how we feel about nudity because I don't
think that these people that this
culture equates nudity with porn I mean
there's you know they go with their
families they go with their little kids
I I lived in Greece for a very small
amount of time and we would go to the
nude beaches and I promise you not only
were these not you know hypersexual
people they were not hypers sexually
attractive people so these are just
people who like to be naked and it
doesn't mean anything other than that
right so in Europe it's just people that
like to be naked versus here are nude
beaches it's always like a lot of old
men hiding behind a bush like yes
fondling himself exactly Ben you've been
there that's where we met was I think uh
but I think Gan is right I think that
and I I think the nudists would would
would bristle at the notion that we want
to sexualize their yeah their desire to
be n is there something a little funny
about the geographic location of this
that it really is going to be pretty
much in urban areas as if these naked
people have to get naked like they're
they're at work and all day long they're
like oh jeez these clothes driving me I
love that I think that's so great yeah
they just they can't keep their clothes
on uh if I might anecdotally tell you a
few weeks ago I may or may not have been
at a clothing optional Spa in Palm
Springs and really you're welcome and um
yep which option did you take and uh
here's the thing these people I mean
yeah there's there's probably people out
there that do it for like you know other
reasons but this particular
Hotel was just people who just aren't
feeling it just aren't feeling closed so
that's the thing I think that these
German people they's not into it man
this hotel would you walk around like be
at the bar and there'd be a naked guy
and he'd be like hey what's going on and
that was it end of and they go back to
his room and water's real cold my
apologies yeah it's just not a big deal
so and I you know whatever you know did
you have any guy say to you hey hey my
mouth is up
here well you know I'm from canas so I'm
I'm obviously you know a liberal you
know super open hippie but you know if
you can just excuse that that's the
thing like it's it's it's not a big deal
to most of the world I don't know about
most of the world to a lot of the world
and if Germans want to sit in the park
uh al fresco I'm I think that's great
well I didn't know we actually had a
legit nudist on the P when I don't know
if you do either so what what what made
you want to go there well it's not my f
i mean what yeah what made you want to
go like you were just like H let me try
it honestly honestly do you want to know
what brought me there this will be like
a 40 Second Story go all right so uh I
was in the desert with some friends I'm
already bored you can shut it I was in
the desert with some friends late in the
day and they were like God I'd love to
go to a mineral spa and I was like I
think it's a little late for that I
think they're all closing I'll see what
I can do and I called this one I just
randomly found it in my phone I was like
I don't know I'll I'll try them they're
on Google I called and I said hi are you
still open do you you know clothing spa
and like oh we're closed I'm so sorry I
was like ah no big deal he goes goes
what's your name and I said Gina and he
goes hm and we talk for a few minutes he
goes let me call you right back so he
calls me right back he goes Gina I like
the cut of your jib he said you sound
like a really really honest person you
sound like a really trustworthy person I
like you a lot tell you what I'm going
to do we're going to leave you the key
what no swear to God are you sure you
didn't just end up at some old P's house
swear to God we thought it was going to
be the world's worst David Lynch movie
but we get there and there are people
there and it's like the this like lot of
statues and like these fountains and
it's so beautiful and we pushed in the
code and we open it's like
shanga and I'm like well when in Rome so
we had an amazing time and I have a
really trustworthy voice
wow follow Gina on
Twitter gor grad just Gina grad just
Gina grad no underscore follow Ben Ben
M77 on Twitter we will do this again
next week should we should we get naked
now as the camera rolls Ben join us
turned on by both of you you're just all
right see
you